foreign  do you know this place it's the old  Mayfair house what do you know about it  murders disappearances but really that  house is famous for its witches  what  tell me about Daniel Emily there's death  had nothing to do with me  but you were there  I don't understand anything that's  happening  the telemask exists to investigate the  uh unexplained  trying to observe the makers your gift  is the strongest thing I've ever felt  to all the mayfairs have gifts  there is something a being he's  connected with your family  you can take different forms  start to visit you  the Devil comes in many forms  [Music]  redeem her soul from Evil oh Lord  use the power that's rightly yours  are you frightened of you shouldn't I be  he serves you not the other way around  you know you're special don't you  Can you feel it  [Music]